um these top two books are
that's why they were at the top
this book look
it's a declaration of independence
this just kind of go
because this is the word that loves to be thrown at us to try to really hurt us
it's oh
so I love to just empower myself with knowledge
how you gonna hurt me if I'm proud of the fucking word myself bitch
love that one
it's a fucking classic
this is actually like the real
this is the 20th anniversary edition
girl this is like number one
feminism 1:01
this one blew my fucking mind though
and this one really fucking pissed me off
when god was a woman
oh my god
this is the one that blew my mind with this book
listen to this bullshit
before humans understood how children were born
women were regarded as fucking goddesses
that's not a myth
they didn't understand where babies came from
all they knew was we're all naked and fuckin
every now and then when you see one of them look really full
uh uh
a baby's gonna come
and then she has a baby and oh my god
these people are goddesses among us
and everybody just lived communally
it was a matriarchal society
and that doesn't mean the opposite of a patriarchy
it's not like women ruled with an iron fist
it was a completely different
you know setting for the culture the way culture was
and the one little bitch who wasn't fucking and participating
must have figured it out
ratted everybody out
figured out what it was
made up all these rules about spilling seed and blah blah blah
entered all these rules
and then god became a man
and now the patriarchy sucks